sinon ouais ça te dérange pas toi le
costume ballon pourquoi tu dis ça que
moi j'ai l'impression que ça me
changeait un peu comme ans a battu ses
avants le samedi soir après l'émission
je rentrais chez moi j'ai attrapé ma
femme vous dis des mots ni monique et
ainsi que je te met une petite cartouche
ou normal
et bien maintenant je m'amuse l'ami made
me présentez moi votre séant afin que je
puisse les honorer
c'est à cause du cosim
certains surtout que ce n'est pas la
première fois que je me le fais
les dernières lorsque je faisais un
soldat allemand dans le führer est en
colère mais le soir je demande à ma
femme de m'attacher au radiateur et deux
matches nuls tornade
c'est le costume de lille
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous présente la nouvelle
émission de thierry ardisson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs bonsoir merci heures pour nous
d'agir pour double ticket les fon pas tu
vois bien je suis en pleine émission
c'est vachement important je prends
personne
hervé bourquel dire avant que halo
non vous ne me dérangeait jamais
président oui c'est jeanne moreau
bah non pas de questions 3 rebonds ça va
sans dire
pas d'allusion à la drogue nous il n'est
pas question
le sexe fort c'est bien que c'est pas le
genre de la maison allez au revoir mais
qu'est ce que tu vas imaginé que tu peux
pas je peux quand même pas avoir le
numéro de téléphone de toutes les filles
courante qui viennent dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
vont jouer avec lui ce soir une
superstar du cinéma américain il a
laissé les douze salopards et les sept
mercenaires pour se rendre justice lui
même
espérons simplement que ce soir il sera
moins silencieux que son arme
charles bronson version new york à lui
charles bronson version far west
alors lequel est le vrai lequel est le
faux lequel est de l'intox lequel et de
l'info pendant que vous cherchez mois
j'anime double jeu notre invité ce soir
lavez les séductrices de la nouvelle
vague la madone des travellings intello
voici tu parce que je suis là j'ai la
mémoire qui flanche j'me souviens plus
très bien de quelle couleur était ses
yeux il était noir ou bleu ah si jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cet ennui pas je vais te poser des
questions qu'on d'accord ta punition
préféré qu est ce que tu préfères f1
s'est mordu piqué j'aimerais mieux mordu
un set un peu érotique ce truc là il me
semble que c'est plus douloureux est
plus agréable en même temps maintenant
je vais te demander de creuser un peu ta
mémoire le mot le plus con en amour
c'est merci encore
oui oui dans l'ordre se seraient encore
ensuite merci bonté coincés dans un
ascenseur est ce que tu préfères être en
compagnie de bhl ppda ou vge qui s'est
vu
valéry giscard d'estaing idiote je peux
pas être tout seul tu as une amie qui
arrivent à l'improviste chez toi et
qu'est ce qui te gênerait le plus
d'avoir sur ta table de nuit
un godemichet ou mein kampf mein kampf
et bien moi ce serait le godemiché
voiture est à choisir est ce que tu
préférerais faire l'amour avec un mec
très laid ou avec une jolie fille un
maître l'est pas très curieuse alors à
qui tu trouves tu le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles je ne
sais pas porter de jugement je crois que
l'un et l'autre doivent avoir une bonne
raison
tolérante penses tu que pour réussir il
failli être ça la tueuse ou calculatrice
je crois que pour réussir vraiment bien
il faut être ni l'une ni l'autre
tu es donc très ambitieuse la bombe
fatale arrive dans cinq minutes
tu fais quoi je regarde par la fenêtre
salut salut
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire
vous connaissez nos amis va très bien on
était voisins quand j'habitais dans son
chalet 177
ah bon oui c'est pas par hasard qu'ils
sont là mais non vous avez trois films à
l'affiché en ce moment
le premier c'est le film de laurent
heynemann qui s'appelle la vieille qui
marchait dans la mer avec ce michel
serrault le deuxième c'est le film de
wim wenders jusqu'au bout du monde et le
troisième c'est un film que j'ai vu
récemment qui s'appelle le pas suspendu
de la cigogne de theo angelopoulos avec
marcello mastroianni et grégory car
alors c'est un film très intéressant
c'est l'histoire d'un homme politique
qui disparaît et un jeune reporter le
retrouve dans un village à la frontière
grecque
et vous vous êtes la femme de cet homme
politique et il vous demande de venir le
reconnaître on y croit elle retrouvait
il croit le retrouver et d'abord cette
femme est très réticente parce que les
années ont passé
elle s'est remariée elle a refait sa vie
comme on dit et on a l'impression
qu'elle n'a pas envie d'être confronté
avec son passé avec cet homme là et puis
finalement elle va avec ce jeune homme
et il se trouve dans cette petite ville
à la frontière de la grèce et de la
yougoslavie et en effet on voit un
individu qui ressemble assez exactement
à cet homme qui était un homme politique
et qui a disparu tout d'un coup ap après
avoir prévu de faire un discours
important à l'équivalent de la chambre
des députés est ce vous qui grimpaient
disco qu'il n'a pas fait et voilà il ya
deux scènes qui sont très jolies et une
scène de mariage qui fait un peu penser
au temps des gitans de kusturica ou
louise marie de chaque côté d'un côté du
foot de chaque côté du fleuve c'est à
dire il ya il ya un marié qui d'un côté
à un marié qui est de l'autre et la
scène de la fin aussi où on voit des
hommes qui travaillent sur des poteaux
électriques des hommes en jaune tracts
aux lectrices un film très graphique
très très beau on va regarder un extrait
[Musique]
mais il faut y aller
puisque
[Musique]
galloway
ah ah
non
là
[Musique]
voilà le pass suspendu de la cigogne de
theo angelopoulos alors dans le film à
un moment donc on vous met en présence
de mastroianni
vous savez pas si c'est lui enfin vous
dit que c'est pas lui en tous les cas
par contre vous vous l'avez vraiment
retrouver ce n'est pas tournée avec lui
depuis la notte d'antonioni absolument
ça faisait 30 ans qu'on est ensemble
mais c'est marrant parce qu'on n'avait
pas l'impression de s'être quittés et
c'était marrant de se retrouver parce
qu'on l'a retrouvé l'homme et la femme
qui s'était connu surtout qu'on avait
été très amoureux l'un de l'autre et on
s'y retrouver échanger mais pas mal vous
l'aviez pas rencontrés depuis trente ans
aussi dans les festivals de cannes
sûrement n'ont pas vraiment bon mais on
savait qu'on existait on a repris des
conversations qu'on n'avait pas terminé
votre premier festival big up 53 54 et
tout de suite on m'avait moi j'étais à
la comédie-française à un sérieux et
tout est la première chose qu'on me dit
on me dit femme née à maillot de bain
j'étais absolument horrifiés en plus je
me trouvais pouvant table et dès que je
suis sorti du train n'est pas qu'on y
allait en train le fameux train bleu
après une nuit complètement dingue où
tout le monde rit bois etc
on a foutu en maillot de bain et on m'a
mise au bord de la mer en général ça
mais cannes c'est jamais très beau alors
un temps gris la mer froid est obligé de
prendre des pauses qui ne vont pas du
tout comme un tablier à une vague alors
qu'il ya des filles qui sont les jouets
autre côté starlette point qu'il ya des
gens qui le font bien moi je
je savais pas faire ça devient petit
maillot à pois j'avais un maillot à pois
que j'avais acheté chez givenchy body
dont alors après le festival vous êtes
allé souvent vous avez eu un prix avec
moderato cantabile c'était en soi sans
pour présidente en 75 oui vous savez que
le festival de cannes va être en
septembre maintenant à nom de l'année
prochaine un peu plus tard ils veulent
attaquer à venise vous allez voir
regarder carne 1991 où le rêve sous le
déluge
est ce la raison pour laquelle les
organisateurs du plus célèbre festival
du cinéma envisageait de changer la
traditionnelle date du mois de mai
depuis il était déjà les rumeurs sont
nombreuses
on cite fréquemment une étude commandée
au mois de juillet par le comité
d'organisation et portant sur la
disponibilité nettement plus importante
des films américains au mois de
septembre
en tout cas si du côté des organisateurs
on se refuse à communiquer toute
décision il nous est possible vous
annoncer aujourd'hui de source sûre que
le 46e festival de cannes aura bien lieu
du 7 au 18 septembre 1993
premièrement parce que pour la
profession cinématographique
étant donné que les gens vont au cinéma
en octobre et pas du tout en juin un
prix décerné en septembre a beaucoup
plus d'impact sur le public qu'un prix
décernés en mai deuxièmement ça évitera
que dans le festival
on est toutes cette tourbe toute cette
écume de gens qui viennent à cannes sans
rien avoir à faire avec le cinéma qui
seront accrédités qui veulent être
invités qui encombrent partout et qui
simplement viennent chercher en mai à
cannes un peu de soleil un peu du
meilleur parce qu'on sort de l'hiver
avoir un festival de cannes au mois de
septembre avec une mention sélectionnés
aucune part festival sur les affiches ça
veut dire qu'ils médiatement récupère le
bénéfice de l'effet médiatique de cannes
la voir au mois de mai pour pas pouvoir
exploiter en salle les retombées de
cannes ça nous intéresse pas parce que
ça fait quatre mois malheureusement les
mois d'été dans la personne en lozère
non
pour l'instant jack lang n'a fait aucune
déclaration la décision n'étant pas
encore officielle mais au ministère de
la culture on ne se félicite pas de ce
changement que l'on attribue à la
pression des producteurs américains
nous n'avons pas été décisionnaire dans
cette affaire on a été consultée très
tardivement et c'est dommage que je ne
sois plus seulement les films qui sont
en compétition mais est festival il est
possible aussi que l'importance du
festival de berlin
l'importance nouvelle du festival de
berlin qui a lieu au début de l'année et
pesé dans la balance
alors le festival de cannes au mois de
septembre dès 1993
la nouvelle devrait être rendue
officielle d'ici un mois
à moins que suite à ce reportage les
organisateurs ne précipite les choses ou
non merci
le festival de cannes 93 au mois de
septembre
est-ce de l'info est de l'intox jeanne
moreau à l'oreille oui alors maintenant
pendant que chez vous vous demandez le
quel est le vrai charles bronson
nous on va écouter la dernière
découverte de prins marty quart
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
le
du temps
[Musique]
aucune
tu as
des tonnes
du
[Musique]
m
son succès
[Musique]
[ __ ]
ford introduit le seul débat
en tenue
[Musique]
ça
m
non
[Musique]
des cas
je
non
[Musique]
vous
torino
[Musique]
qu'une bulle c'est le sens
et demain
je nettoie
[Musique]
non
[ __ ]
il
le festival de cannes 93 aura tillion
septembre s de l'info est de l'intox
charles bronson new york
à toi de jouer tu dis que c'est de
l'info toi - pourquoi moi parce que je
subis cannes ouais je crois d'avoir lu
sur la presse là bas dans la presse le
cadre est bien placé pour le savoir
oui et toi brunson far west un je dis
que c'est de l'intox
tu dis que c'est de l'intox pense qu'il
ya le festival de deauville le quai très
rapprochées way bleu mais je peux le
dire maintenant jeanne m'a dit que
c'était de la faune alors on va savoir
écouter votre expert philippe guerre eh
bien mon cher thierry avant de donner la
réponse je voudrais demander à jeanne
moreau de nous accorder une petite
faveur
jeanne est ce que vous accepteriez si
vous n'avez pas tous bons à toutes les
réponses de faire pour nous un petit
gages
ok oui est ce que vous pourriez nous
chanter un petit couplet d'un de vos
airs dont je suis un fan et à mon avis
je ne suis pas le seul d'accord pas
d'accord alors voici la réponse c'est de
l'intox aux bravos
[Applaudissements]
le corps le score ça fait 1 0 pour le
cow boy à 1 0 pour le cowboy bravo on
l'applaudît philippe klein commentaire à
faire là-dessus tu peux nous expliquer
oui thierry c'est de l'intox encore que
les producteurs américains et les
distributeurs de films font pression sur
les organisateurs pour que le festival
de cannes soit déplacé de mai à
septembre
mais rassurez vous j'ai eu
personnellement ligne france where
lembach qui est le secrétaire général du
festival de cannes
il n'est plus du tout question de
déplacer le festival de mai à septembre
une fois seulement la france avait
accepté de faire plaisir c'était en 1939
pour le premier festival à la demande
pressante de nos amis allemands nous
avions dû attendre sept ans avant
d'avoir le premier festival
mais rassurez-vous c'en est fini des
pressions pour n'applaudit pour faire
d'ici la fin de la mission
peut-être alors j'aime quand vous parlez
de vos échecs dans les interviews
parlait toujours de la nuit de l'iguane
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
pas d'avoir marqué en tous les cas
bah oui parce que ça n'est pas tellement
arrivée est bien très peu de critiques
dramatiques en amérique et c'est le
critique de washington post qui est venu
sans être invité qui a écrit tout de
suite le papier mais qui était
désastreux pour tout le spectacle pour
tout le monde et bien sûr moi qui jouais
un rôle très important
et après quelques jours de réflexion je
lui ai envoyé un mot pour remercier la
gt pas la hauteur quoi maintenant tout
va bien sûr depuis la rentrée veut une
presse dithyrambique la turbo sous vos
trois films est ce que l'avis de la
presse vous touche
elle me touche pour le destin du film
mais au moment où je fais les choses et
même après que je les ai faites
j'ai une espèce de voix intérieures jai
un juge suprême et je sais s'il ya
quelque chose qui cloche ou s'il ya
quelque chose qui est vraiment exact
et sincère et si j'ai donné le meilleur
de moi même donc c'est important et sam
n'est pas l'avis des gens autour de vous
certaines personnes qui sont un peu des
juges lui ont été demandées dans la rue
à des gens ce qu'ils pensaient en
sortant d'un film qui s'appelle la
vieille qui marchait dans la mer laurent
baffie costard de stars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avez vous trouvé jeanne moreau dans ce
film pareil à elle même elle est
toujours sympathique
je voudrais bien
elle est formidable quelle est la scène
que vous avez préféré tout en général je
peux pas longueur
est ce que ça vous a choqué la scène
d'amour entre le moine trappiste et
l'iguane j'ai souhaité beaucoup de monde
et lorsque le shérif et l'amour ou chez
phadia il ya un symbole pour vous
oui oui bien sûr lequel il ya
l'amour de une attirance mutuelle vous
avez pleuré à la fin du film lorsque
bambi dénonce amer aux allemands il ya
toujours une petite émotion quelle est
la meilleure scène de film à votre avis
la meilleure bas vers le début quand un
couple non tu veux donc n'importe quoi
qu'elle est on reprend quelle est la
meilleure scène du film à votre avis la
meilleure scène du film toy lembras quel
est à votre avis la plus belle scène du
film au début quand on a va qui marche
quand le troupeau d'éléphants rentrer
dans sacré coeur sur la musique du
dernier et 47 our lives de georgette
lemaire ça vous a plu cette semaine
ouais mais je trouve ce sont des
situations extrêmement improbable et
quelle est la casquette que vous avez
préféré la cascade la cascade
quand il se jette du vide mais il se
jette dans le vide ça a été un vrai les
séquences la séquence c'est quand ça
dans le vers la fin quand ici avec la
voiture
c'est un film en costumes d'époque n'y a
pas de voie du non mais attendez qu est
ce que vous racontez c'est pour me
vanter des conneries c'est quoi la peur
mais je n'ai pas vu outils
alors pourquoi vous m'en parlez ce n'est
pas lui c'est insensé votre comportement
qu'est ce que je vous ai dit mais c'est
insensé ça vraiment les gens veulent
parler de tout sans jamais rien l'avoir
vu
les gens sont prêts à faire n'importe
quoi donc rassurez vous la prochaine
fois que vous entendrez parler d'un beau
film marquant 6 et du bien vous le
prenez cissé du mal vous laisse tomber
vous voyez m alors vous connaissez la
terre entière et je vous faire une
interview vous ou dire que je vais vous
citer des noms de gens ah oui c'est
terrible ça mais pas pour vous faire
chier c'est nous qui gagnons à vous
écouter
alors je vous citer des noms de gens et
vous réagissez présente louis malle
tianwan vous l'avez beaucoup aimé vous
l'aimez toujours touchant vous croyez
que vous avez fait d'abord un ascenseur
pour l'échafaud avec les à main et les
amants de la fidesz autres films ensuite
on va en parler mais est ce que vous
auriez fait les amants si vous n'aviez
pas été excusez-moi amont avec lui quand
même très bien pas du tout vous l'auriez
pas fait vous l'auriez fait n'aurait pas
été possible sans ennui et sans moi
après vous avez fait viva maria et la
huent un peu des problèmes parce que de
le dire maintenant il ya prescription
bardot quand même je faisais un peu
chier quoi son nom n'y a pas vraiment
une langue c'est vrai qu'elle était un
peu chiante
mais c'était vécu en tout cas par mois
tout à fait bien pour vous oui oui mais
parce qu'il y avait tous ces
journalistes tous ces photographes
autour et ce qui comptait pour les
médias c'était la rivalité s'était alors
que rivalité il y en avait absolument
pas mais quelquefois c'était emmerdant
datant du 8 heures une chaleur de plomb
c'était pas toujours alors je lui
demandais de me prévenir quand même se
révéla mais c'est difficile non api lui
s'occupait plus d'elle parce qu'avec
vous il savait que c'était réglé un peu
dans que de la bonne intention elle
quand même temps il ne faisait parce
qu'il a la santé beaucoup plus fragile
il la santé beaucoup plus fragiles c'est
vrai que quelquefois je ne prenais pas
très bien de sa part à lui orson welles
voulait connu en quelle année c'est
qu'on est
je débutais presque j'ai connu à la
comédie française
ça devait être en 1951 est gelée suivi
toute sa vie les demandes du peuple
il a jamais été très minces ils étaient
ils étaient ballon et puis j'ai jamais
pensé à sa corpulence
après je me suis pas inquiété un petit
peu inquiété mais c'était à cause de sa
fragilité de sa santé et lorsque je le
sentais malheureux mais j'ai toujours
trouvé beau c'est vrai qu'il n'aimait
pas qu'on le voit manger
non il n'y avait pas sympa qu'un jour le
v surpris en espagne en train de manger
oui à ma gauche anglais mais d un cochon
de lait entier qui la met devant lui on
m'avait donné une adresse à côté de
madrid et j'y suis allé avec un ami il y
avait personne et on nous a proposé
différentes salles une sorte d'auberge
et puis j'ai ouvert une porte et or ce
n'était là j'ai vu qu'il était féru j'ai
fait comme si je ne l'avais pas vu et un
jour vous a proposé de tout quitter pour
le film aux états unis vous n'êtes pas
parti
tout quitter ils voulaient payer le
dédit de la comédie française
bunuel c'est un homme que j'aurais pu
aimer follement s'il avait été un peu
plus jeunes ont marqué son jeune âge
mais je n'ai pas mes sens gêné lui alors
je dis lui disais que j'aurais aimé
qu'il soit mon père elle lui me disait
que j'avais tort parce qu'il aurait été
absolument tyrannie qui m'aurait
sûrement enfermé dans un placard
il nous aurait pas laissé faire du
cinéma merci à martin un peu comme votre
père oui mais mon père pendant 13 ans et
alex était né gallas il serait devenu
elle vous raconter ça qui quand tu étais
petit bolide qu'il était sensible mais
pas sentimental
oui c'est très sympa retrouvés et que
quand ils étaient petits pendant qu'ils
travaillent y mettait du sparadrap sur
la bouche de sa soeur quand il était
petit quand ta bonté grand ah bon mais
oui
et quand il était grand candy
travaillait avec jean claude carrière
et puis mettez du sparadrap sur la
bouche de sa soeur parce qu'elle était
trop bavard dit non alors vais
travailler dans nikita avec besson et
vous vous êtes assez fasciné par sa
recherche du graal ce que vous appelez
ça recherche du graal oui oui parce
qu'il est obsédé comme tous les hommes
dont nous avons parlé ne peut être d'une
façon parce qu'il est plus jeune et
qu'il appartient à cette époque dans
laquelle nous vivons
ça n'est pas détournée par la
littérature ni par un art plastique
c'est cinéma cinéma cinémas et quand
nous avons travaillé ensemble j'ai
tourné quoi quinze jours dans les états
je me suis amusé parce qu'ils
s'amusaient absolument follement il
faisait refaire les scènes tu peux le
faire un peu comme ça appuie si on
essayait comme ça un peu plus triste un
peu plus gai plus lent plus rap et on
sentait que ça pouvait durer durer vous
pardonner tous au réalisateur faiblesse
ou accéder vous appelez ça des
particularités pour pas dire des défauts
oui oui il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de des
fonds alors gérard philipe en un mot
j'étais tellement en extase béate qui
m'est arrivé d'oublier mon texte
c'est embêtant bah oui et puis surtout
dans le prince et hambourg avoir un trou
dans la salle
dans la cour du palais des papes s'est
mis à le vent qui passe m
gaba b to b avec le ghana oui mais moi
j'aime tous les hommes avec lesquels
j'ai travaillé
lino ventura faisait travailler avec lui
oui dans le gris ce milieu et puis j'ai
fait un film alors là je suis là j'ai
oublié le titre
avant on préférait l'oublier non pas du
tout c'est qu'il était catcheur lino
ventura alors oui je sais on va avoir
une histoire de quelqu'un d'autre dont
il paraît qu'il aurait été catcheur on
regarde
le vrai faux journal la suite bonjour en
bon gros jovial il joue à nous amuser
chaque midi
et pourtant sous son aspect bon enfant
le journaliste claude villers cache bien
son jeu
mais pourquoi tant de haine claude
miller j'étais un petit garçon en gros
qui vient sur se faisait chahuté à
l'école alors sans arrêt c'était la
patate la grosse et tout est un jour je
me suis dit il m'ennuie
pour être poli je vais leur casser la
gueule et pour faire les choses à fond
il est devenu catcheur professionnel bel
et bien sûr celle sur cette arrivée sur
leurs idées sur le ring avec 12 au noir
clouté la chaîne de vélo à la main etc
c'était la grande époque du catch claude
villers faisait trembler la france de
1958 à 1961 il fut l'un des quatre
frères masqué d'une troupe de catch
ambulant c'est marquant il a toujours
joué le rôle du méchant mal aimé mais
pourquoi claude villers vous savez c'est
le drame des gros le gros c'est celui
qui retrace l'épopée invaincu la tarte à
la crème dans la figure haschich et le
caucus et le cto chambre ont voté mots
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
dans un gymnase
il retrouve ses anciennes amours et
égrène ses souvenirs d'anciens
combattants j'en at il dit c'est que je
suis arrivé en revanche a terminé sa
carrière comme receveur des postes à
avril mais dit aussi sur les
enseignements qu'il en a tiré
ça fait partie du rêve le catch c'est
pour moi c'est une manière de raconter
les histoires d'abord moi j'aime bien
raconter des histoires ça a été une
université à moi
journaliste puis animateur de radio les
histoires ils nous racontent tous les
jours depuis presque trente ans avec
entre autres le tribunal des flagrants
délires et son bref au journal
aujourd'hui une belle carrière qui
laisse quelques regrets à certains un
petit pois comme il était alors catcheur
avant d'être journaliste s de l'info est
de l'intox
jeanne moreau à l'oreille oui alors
maintenant pendant que nos amis branson
et bronson réfléchit cependant que vous
chez vous vous chercher pour savoir
c'est de l'info si c'est de l'intox
nous on va se faire très plaisir on va
écouter jeanne morts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche j'me
souviens plus très bien rond comme il
était très musiciens il jouait beaucoup
des mères
deux d'entre nous à commencer par un
très long baiser sur la vérité du
poignet un long baiser sans peuple
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche j'me
souviens plus très bien
quel pouvait être sans prénom et quel
était son nom
il s'appelait je l'appelais comment la
belette dents
pourtant c'est fou ce que j'aimais
l'appeler par son nom
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche j'me
souviens plus très bien
de quelle couleur était ses yeux je
crois pas qu'ils étaient bleus
était une verte et une grille
à tâter le vert de gris
aux changes est il tout en couleurs pour
un envoi oui on s'est connus on s'est
reconnus
non ces merdes élevé
air perdus de vue on s'est retrouvé au
s'est réchauffé puisant s'est séparé
chacun pour soi on est parti dans un
tourbillon de la vie
j'ai revu un soin la lamelle et moi
tomber dans mes bras elle est retombé
dans mes bras en temps c'est connu quand
on s'est reconnus
pourquoi ce perdre de vue leur perdre de
vue quand on s'est retrouvé devant s'est
réchauffée pourquoi se sait
alors tous non les
parti dans le tourbillon de la vie
on a continué
la tournée tous les deux
lassé
tous les deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant claude miller catcheur
avant d'être journaliste s de l'info s
de l'intox c'est à toi de jouer le
brunson version far west à ton avis je
dis que c'est de l'info tu dis que c'est
de la faute oies et pourquoi
et c'est à dire je joue un peu sur les
probabilités a passé le premier que je
vois personne qui va maintenant et toi
alors également jeudi que c'est de
l'info vous m'avez dit c'était de
l'intox
je suis inquiet là pour moi durant la
voir philippe s de la prouesse de
l'intox
ma pauvre jeanne on a déjà un couplet je
crois qu'on en a deux enfin totalement
de l'info on applaudit l'ordinaire
jean r alors quel est le score laurent 2
1 pour le cow boy bandit dont 1
philippe est ce que tu as un commentaire
à faire et oui c'est de l'info claude
villers n'a pas vraiment un physique de
patineurs artistiques
il est la preuve vivante et vivante
qu'il ne faut pas forcément coucher pour
arriver dans ce métier n'est ce pas ma
fille je ne sais pas c'est pas pour dire
mais deux fois que vous vous trompez est
ce que vous êtes riche vais rien vu quoi
non j'ai pas grand chose je vis avec ce
que je gagne ou sur le chemin quand vous
avez vendu votre propriété du prix
berges de la garde freinet mecs sont
hectares quand même mais bien de toucher
de l'argent mais j'avais des dettes puis
je venais de divorcer et contrairement à
ce qu'on pense un divorce américain ça
peut coûter cher et soudé tout au
contraire
et dans ces moments là quand vous aviez
vraiment besoin d'argent est ce que vous
avez pensé à faire la publicité ah non
non j'ai fait des émissions de radio
radio monte carlo j'ai raconté la vie
des stars je voyageais beaucoup c'était
assez étonnant d'ailleurs c'était une
période où j'avais pas un rond j'ai même
pas de quoi prendre un taxi
j'ai pas tellement longtemps ses 1,80 et
j'étais invité partout alors on faisait
un hommage à jeanne moreau à san
francisco un autre à chicago j'étais
invité à boston je voyager en première
classe gt habillé par les grands
couturiers qui prêtait des vêtements et
j'étais logé dans des palaces et
heureusement que j'avais des amis ou
comme invitée à dîner mais je pouvais
sans rien sans de l'avion veut plus
d'argent non mais la vie est formidable
parce que j'ai trouvé sur mon chemin où
des gens sont menées à ma rencontre et
je n'ai jamais désespéré il y avait
toujours quelqu'un qui me donnait 100
francs ou ça s'emballe et ça s'est
toujours bien passé mais c'est vous
honneur parce que c'est pas le cas de
toutes les stars on va voir le magazine
du faux les arnaques de stars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d' arnaque aussi
célèbre que leurs auteurs l'histoire de
star qui pensent que plus on est riche
et célèbre
et plus on en veut pour alimenter son
compte en suisse pour cela tous les
moyens sont bons mais les ethnologues
vous le diront comme dans la mafia
chaque clan a ses spécialités
hors-d'oeuvre voici le gris gris qui
rapporte avec danièle gilbert
elle avait troqué sa vraie candeur de
belle fille idéale pour devenir
marchande de banyuls pharaonique au
pseudo propriété est florissante
guy lux lui proposait ses lumières aux
amateurs du loto des chiffres permettant
de décrocher le gros lot dans un délai
de six mois
les numéros en question ont été choisis
par un ordinateur l'union départementale
des consommateurs des alpes-maritimes
n'a pas apprécié inculpation un peu de
piment maintenant avec le recel d'objets
d'art volées ces moustiques ex chanteur
de rock des années 60
reconverti dans la brocante vous n'en
pouvez plus vous avez besoin d'un petit
régime ne vous adressez pas à
l'illusionniste dominique webb
il n'a réussi ni à faire maigrir les
dodus ni à hypnotiser son juge
voici maintenant les sportifs du trafic
ou plutôt les trafics des sportifs
convaincus de trafic de drogue diego
maradona s'est enfui vers son pays
l'argentine
les napolitains ne veulent plus entendre
parler de leur ancienne idole un comble
dans la capitale italienne de tous les
trafics
enfin le dessert voici les sportifs qui
passe par la case prison sans même avoir
touché un centime
comme mike tyson par exemple qui
n'aurait pas hésité à violer la
concurrente d'un concours de beauté
heureusement l'amérique qui n'est pas
rancunière la laisser sortir pour jouer
son dernier match car le public qui a
toujours adoré les stars et les voleurs
les aime encore plus quand ils sont les
deux
dr voilà ce qui vous aurez aurait pu lui
arriver
si vous n'aviez pas votre rigueur
naturel alors une ou deux films que vous
avez tourné qui s'appelle anna karamazov
voulait tourner à moscou est allé line
grade
est-ce que vous comme beaucoup d'acteurs
de votre génération
vous avez été tenté à un moment par le
par le communisme ne change jamais je
n'ai aucune chinoise n'avait jamais cru
même nom votre papa qui vous avez donnés
cette éducation qui vous avez dit vous
méfier ou pas du tout pas du vent donc
c'est peut-être justement mon père était
restaurateur il avait un café c'est
plein à force d'entendre les
conversations de bistrot de bistrot que
non non c'est à l'époque quand vous
voyez je sais pas il montand signoret
qui partait en urss
ça vous tue pas vous les trouviez
ridicule vous aviez envie de leur dire
de payal et non non non puisque je suis
pas militante
d'ailleurs pendant très longtemps j'ai
eu un sentiment de culpabilité de ne pas
être aussi tranchée de ne pas d'avoir
des avis sur tout et puis le privilège
de l'âge c'est que maintenant je peux
dire franchement ouvertement que non
l'histoire vous a donné raison en
quelque sorte oui est ce que vous pensez
puisqu'on en parle régulièrement dans la
presse
est-ce que vous pensez que la monarchie
représente un avenir pour ces pays là
quand on voit le roi de roumanie qui
essayent de revenir le roi de bulgarie
le roi de yougoslavie
le grand duc qui va à leningrad je crois
que c'est un avenir où vous pouvez qui
sont encore des séquelles des scories
qui traînent dans la tête des gens et la
connaissance que j'ai du monde sait que
rien ne recommence jamais mais je peux
pas répondre sur ces shoes mark hurd
alors d'accord
en 1919 le traité de trianon rend son
indépendance à la slovaquie bratislava
s'affranchit de la tutelle tchèque avec
à sa tête car le trois descendants de la
dynastie d'été chaîne qui avait fondé au
9e siècle l'état slovaque
car le 3 reste au pouvoir jusqu'en 1938
où il est chassé de son pays par
monseigneur tisot un proche des nazis
l'héritier au trône antonin 1er net en
exil en 1951 à paris où il vit toujours
en cultivant la nostalgie de son pays
oui effectivement mon premier souhait
serait de visiter tout simplement mon
propre pays que je n'ai jamais vue
d'aller à la rencontre des gens tout
simplement un souhait comme quelqu'un
qui est expatrié qui voudraient voir de
là où il vient où sont ses racines
le projet de visite devient affaire
d'état comme à bucarest où michel de
roumanie a été refoulé dès son arrivée
prague refuse d'accorder tout visa a en
tout d'un premier vaclav havel l'a
encore rappelé dans une déclaration le 2
novembre dernier le retour d'antonin
premier représente une réelle menace
pour lindt et tchécoslovaques et une
vision réaliste des faits nous amène à
penser que les sentiments nationalistes
slovaques sont développées par d'anciens
dirigeants communistes aux menaces
peuvent slovaque a aussi envie d'exister
donc d'une certaine manière ils ont
trouvé le peuple slovaque a trouvé dans
le prince et ona une figure emblématique
qui pourrait servir de porte drapeau
finalement de cette mémoire collective
la famille d'été chaîne incarne la
résistance lovable toujours vivace
vis-à-vis des tchèques témoins les 14 %
de suffrages recueillis par le parti
monarchiste slovaque aux dernières
élections
même si le prince entonna n'a pas de
projet politique
enfin oui enfin je me suis imaginé on
voit maintenant sérieusement
il est un devoir pour moi ou cas où les
slovaques le souhaitent de les aider je
veux dire n'importe quel citoyen le feu
tout comme alexandre de yougoslavie ou
siméon de bulgarie le prince antonin
n'est pas un coup de schiste en
attendant l'appel de son peuple qu'ils
rêvent simplement d'un bain de foule
parmi les siens le prétendant aux crèmes
de slovaquie interdit de séjour par
vaclav havel s de l'info est de l'intox
jeanne moreau à l'oreille oui alors
maintenant pendant que nos amis branson
et bronson réfléchit cependant que vous
chez vous vous chercher pour savoir
c'est de l'info si c'est de l'intox
nous on écoute les rembrandt très très
très bien placé sur la playlist de
double jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
when you
mais
paul
[Musique]
douze citoyens
à
ce faire
ce pas
[Musique]
on fait
à cholet
là
un cap et je te
m
[Musique]
vainqueur
et
respect
[Musique]
natsume
le
à
[Musique]
je
op
tu
[Musique]
acheteurs wima paillis
ma mère
g
oh
[Musique]
du
ouais
je l'espère
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
ce sens
[Musique]
alors le prétendant au trône le slovaque
qui interdit de séjour par vaclav havel
s de l'info est de l'intox
cette fois de jouer charles tu dis que
c'est de l'info toi ouais pourquoi je
suis pas un si mauvais qu'ils chantent
toujours l'intuition go et jusqu'à
présent ça n'a pas tellement évident
non mais tu continues comme ça tu es toi
ça je dis que c'est les fausses tu dis
que c'est de l'info d'accord tous les
trois mois le jeune mort ok quand même
déjà deux couplets nous a dit que
c'était la pause tous les trois pour
l'info on écoute l'expert philippe guère
écouté jeanne je crois qu'on s'achemine
directement vers la compilation des
oeuvres de jeanne moreau à la fin de
cette émission seulement parce que c'est
totalement totalement totalement de
l'intox ont applaudi dans la compétition
bah oui la preuve alors laurent quel est
le score le score on s'en fout c'est
brunson qui va gagner enfin de toute
façon tu as raison la loi pour le cow
boy et ça fait trois couples et pour
jeanne moreau philippe est ce que tu as
un commentaire à faire oui thierry c'est
de l'intox tout dans ce sujet absolument
tout est faux les photos le faux prince
qui entre parenthèses ces timbres est
noble mais français nous avons trouvé
l'un des seuls pays de l'est à n'avoir
aucun prétendant
la slovaquie est en effet le seul pays
de l'est à ne pas avoir été une
monarchie dans son histoire
thierry excuse moi mais ça n'est pas moi
qui ai inventé la slovaquie bon là
planifie ligue 1
alors maintenant on peut le révéler ce
stade de l'émission votre mère était
danseuse ici jeanne aux folies bergère
vous étiez venu donc quand vous étiez
non pas du tout l'été pas encore
enceinte de moi à elle a dansé ici pour
la première fois elle avait 18 ans oui
elle faisait partie de la troupe de tino
girl qui accompagne et joséphine
bancaire quand elle a débuté ici
moi je suis arrivé après j'ai interrompu
la carrière de ma mère et c'était un
sujet tabou à la maison on n'en parlait
pas non jamais ma mère m'en parlait plus
tard mon appareil plus tard quand en
cachette et puis en fouillant dans les
affaires dans l'armoire
j'ai trouvé une espèce de vieille
vieille boîte est dedans il y avait des
photos sublimes de maman
danseuse et alors quand vous êtes arrivé
ici tout à l'heure vous êtes venus ici
pour la première fois c'est la première
fois la première fois je mettais les
pieds ici c'est pas mal c'était très
touchant
votre père lui était restaurateur paul
moreau il avait un restaurant un moment
oui il s'appelait la cloche d'or la wii
il a avec son frère arsène mais il a
vécu assez tard pour voir votre succès
puisqu'il était avec vous a été bâtie
compris il était très fier qu'un timmins
au spectacle par exemple
tous joueront le placer au deuxième rang
ce qui me désole parce qu'il s'endormait
au bout d'un quart d'heure
mais avant de s'endormir aideront flux
comme un sonneur il prenait le temps de
dire eh oh c'est ma fille c'est ma fille
puis après de remettre et puis ça tu y
voyait les films mais c'est dégueulasse
tu te laisse embrasser par gabin ce
vieux con il pourrait tomber oui et
c'était intéressant comme commentaire et
il était fier mais en même temps ils ne
comprenaient pas ce qui l'a réconcilié
avec moi c'est que j'ai une très bonne
cuisinière voilà donc ils voyaient que
je savais faire quelque chose de mes dix
doigts dans le restaurant de votre père
vous ne travaillez pas du tout vous vous
étiez pas non c'est pas la main à la
pâte
non mais y amène une cousine il ya de
mon père
julienne qui était une femme épatante
j'ai connu des femmes vraiment
formidable et qui avait une auberge et
je servais les pourboires justement
maintenant vous me faites un
enchaînement formidable on va regarder
le bas fichaux une histoire de
l'histoire
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle vaut la petite dame et
un grand capitaine léger et 3 6 3 sucre
un verre d'eau et le parti sorti un café
crème un verre d'eau à des 4ème et bien
d'autres vous avez une ordonnance ya
plus de tartines
vous voulez une autre cote non merci à
ceux conduits
vous voulez un bout de cake non qu'est
ce que vous allez prendre mais c'est
parce qu'il faut qu'on fasse du chiffre
non non non vous voulez que je vous
parle un petit peu non pas du tout ça va
vous en ce moment non non parce que moi
j'ai déjà des problèmes
boucher schéma qui il a capté une grippe
dans une grille par les clippers et puis
charles picqué inquiet parce que ça fait
quand même huit jours que là bas et à
l'école il est venu de médecin il est
venu mais on n'était pas là dans l'été
sorti comme des dépouilles d'enfants et
émana oui parce qu'on avait une soirée
avec des copains dans une boîte
échangiste
on était au fournil club et des soirées
lundi vous connaissez alors vous vous
êtes mariés
la première fois c'était en 49 avec jean
richard changer son nom parce que ça
ressemblait à jean richard hein et vous
est retrouvée enceinte est en fait le
mariage a eu lieu la veille de
l'accouchement
un samedi c'est gratuit et puis c'était
juste à voir ouais c'était juste avant
ce qui fait que le photographe il était
obligé de marc descendez l'escalier on
m'avait prêté un grand manteau et jeudi
au nom pas très très mal hier mais
madame la tête seulement si vous n'aviez
pas été en simple vous seriez marier
quand même non c'est franck vous avez eu
un enfant jérôme qui a 42 ans
aujourd'hui
vous le voyez souvent tu le vois en ce
moment à peu près une fois par an oui il
vit en californie
vous vous dites j'ai eu un enfant mais
je n'ai jamais été maire c'est dur à
dire ça qu'on m'a mis non pas du tout je
suis maire ce que j'ai dit je mettais ma
monteuse interne en intervenant par mail
dans le sens conventionnel
ensuite vous avez une liaison suis pas
secret avec pierre cardin
oui et puis vous vous êtes mariés pour
la deuxième fois avec le réaliser c'est
quoi un vrai amour qardaoui ça dure et
combien de temps ça dure et plus 4 en
dépit après vous être marié ou donc avec
le réalisateur de l'exorciste et de
french connection williams fait qu'ils
n'ont pu vous êtes mariés parce que ça
vous a touché qui vous demande en
mariage mais ça m'a beaucoup c'est la
première fois qu'on vous demandait en
mariage vous avez des en fait oui alors
ce divorce était quelque chose
d'épouvantable vous parlez de d'années
noires
le fait que j'ai accepté je lui accorder
une valeur un peu sacré et
j'ai souffert de cette disproportion
entre mon désir et la réalité
non pas que je me sentais responsable et
non pas que je le trouvais lui
responsable mais ça a été une douleur
très violente et très profonde
ça vous a coûté de l'argent en plus
c'est un drame c'est pas grave vous
n'étiez pas très au courant des
banquiers des avocats tous avouent né
pas voulu être au courant non c'est pas
grave j'étais surtout la déchirure
clientèle
vous dites je ne pense pas dans ma vie
avoir aimé un homme à avoir il a non
c'est pas grave du tout bon je me
reconnais juillet la plupart des gens
sont comme moi on est amoureux on est
passionnément attaché on repousse
violemment mais l'amour
l'alliance ce que j'appelle l'alliance
c'est à dire un échange profond à des
intéressés un amour absolu
je n'ai pas connu en tout cas moi je
n'ai pas connu vous regrettez oui
quelque part j'espère le connaître avant
de mourir oui et peut-être que ça ne
sera pas sous la forme peu tout le monde
peut imaginer maintenant on va voir un
sujet quand même avoir ça vous changer
les idées s'est consacré à la guerre
[Musique]
en janvier 1993 lorsque douvres sera
relié à calais par le tunnel sous la
manche l'angleterre ne sera plus tout à
fait une île la manche qui a toujours
préservé le royaume uni des invasions ne
pourra plus alors jouer son rôle de
rempart naturel contre l'ennemi le
secret défense est maintenant levé et le
times du 11 novembre dernier révèle que
le tunnel peut être inondée en cas de
conflit au moment de la signature du
traité
j'en ai moins en a eu vent de une
préparatifs qui ne se faisait pour la
défense nationale anglaise qui a demandé
le changement au plan du tunnel mais
nous ne savions pas quoi exactement
personnes voulaient nous dire c'était un
secret nous avons insisté auprès des des
gens à londres des ministres des
transports et de défense sans rien voir
jusqu'à récemment quand je pense le
gouvernement anglais a voulu calmer un
peu les inquiétudes du public anglaise
de qu'est-ce qui se passerait en cas
d'invasion
est ce que quelque chose de sérieux
était prévu sur ordre du premier
ministre britannique
löw pourra s'engouffrer dans le tunnel
grâce à une série de conduire ollier au
fond de la mer en quelques heures la
partie centrale du tunnel sera inondé
soit treize des 37 km inve sous la
manche
et selon le times selva janvier 1986 le
jour de la signature du traité sur le
tunnel ferroviaire que le principe d'un
dispositif de sécurité fut adopté une
destruction par l'armé nucléaire et en
définitive tom quinn ministre de la
défense de l'époque préféra le système
d'inondations qui permet une remise en
état ultérieure du tunnel mais le tunnel
at il une réelle importance stratégique
pour le gouvernement britannique il est
très important de neutraliser le tunnel
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen d'une
occupation terrestre
aujourd'hui certes on fait d'abord la
guerre avec l'aviation avec les missiles
mais il s'agit ensuite de concrétiser la
victoire par une conquête terrestre est
donc coupée le tunnel c'est freiner une
invasion mais rappelez-vous ce
stratagème a déjà été utilisé dans
l'histoire alors moy serait il entré
dans les services secrets britanniques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tunnel sous la manche inondable en
cas de guerre s de l'info s de la tête
jeanne moreau à l'oreille j'aimerais
bien gagner ouais ouais
alors maintenant pendant que vous
chercher chez vous pour savoir si c'est
de l'info ou si c'est de l'intox
pendant que vous allez chercher une
bière dans le frigo nous on va regarder
quelqu'un dont on a vu le fils arthur
ashe il ya quelques semaines
aujourd'hui c'est la balade qu'il a fait
pour sa fille izia jacques higelin
peut-être ce qui m'a
tirant toi tirs
en quoi
et rien que l'autre vert
cent deux mois sans deux mois on
m'attendait les champs
[Musique]
caché derrière
port
les portes du ciel
rien de tout ce qu'ils m'ont speer en
toi pire en toi
mais plus tout cru grâce
de ta peau de taches noires
dans la magie pro vie d'avant cieux
m'en sors tu l'aimés score jusqu'aux
portes du ciel
doux
d'où viens-tu ou m'attendre merveille
on
on avoue
seul
r c'est pas
l'eau des sortilèges et des rêves
étoilés
sous la grand mère
[Musique]
et peut-être ce qui me re ly à toualy à
toi
et d'autres que ces corps
dans de soi don
deux soirs
petit mort ou le tout
tu
[Musique]
on l'empêché de courir
software
et si tout ce que j'adore en toi dort en
moi je veux que tu le réveil en moiré
pour toi pour que de la terre
[Musique]
sow
et
de nos carrières
mais ce n'est pas sienne
[Musique]
vers 6 heures balade parisien les
filiales sous la manche inondable en cas
de guerre s de l'info est de l'intox
c'est à charles de jouer à ton avis
critique c'est de l'intox
tu dis que c'est de l'intox tout a été
calculé depuis longtemps ouais et toi
charles alors je peux le dire maintenant
jeanne m'a dit que c'était de l'intox a
on va voir si vous avez chanté toute la
chanson où seulement trois couples et
philippe jeanne je crois que vous faites
une quinzaine d'émissions avec nous vous
allez très très forte à ce jeu là
puisque vous avez gagné bravo c'était de
l'intox donc d'être obligé de s'exécuter
nous chanter la chanson goulaine sont
toutes bien j'aime ton odeur ta saveurs
les ont crus tep hab oignons dans les
cheveux longs mais je t'ai dans la peau
mais je t'ai dans la peau les os je ne
suis pas joli joli
nous ne sommes pas bobo mais entre toi
moi je grille
tu me fout le feu à la peau tu as
peut-être pas des bras d'athlètes tu as
peut-être pas le torse velu
mais j'adore retenir être chaque fois tu
dis tu m'as dans la poule i only war
beau
[Applaudissements]
j'ai de bonnes dents soutenir aussi une
très bonne mémoire
alors laurent quel est le score final à
la surprise générale c'est charles
bronson qui a gagné le cowboy trois
points à 1
je prends ton petit téléviseur
tu va regarder tous les cadeaux qui
défilent et il va me dire celui que tu
veux
le mini téléviseurs philips à cristaux
liquides multistandard pal secam 69
programme mémorisable merci bravo au
tapis
alors pour toi l'intégrale de 37,2
sommes habitués à continuer la nuit tout
à fait bien on applaudit aussi fait
psychanalyse est un moment de votre vie
mais est-ce que vous êtes confessé dans
votre vie ah oui quand j'étais petit
vous ont gardé un bon souvenir
pas terrible aïe aïe aïe je crains pour
moi alors à maintenant je suis plus
grande ça va être intéressant
bon ben on y va alors à terme une
confession jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand vous étiez petit il vous avait
réellement voulu être religieuse oui je
devais avoir 5 ans j'ai été frappé par
le rituel égalité d'humeur
c'est à dire que dans la vie à la maison
c'était plutôt en dents de scie j'aimais
la musique j'aimais l'ordonance voilà
j'aime beaucoup la rigueur quand vous
dites j'ai un maître intérieur de qui
s'agit-il
je veux dire qu'à partir du moment où on
n'est pas perméable comme une éponge et
où on ne se laisse pas influencer par
tout ce qui nous entoure et qu'on ne vit
pas que par rapport au regard des autres
au jugement des autres
cette voie là s'expriment vous avez
toujours préféré le terme sensualité et
sexualité est un peu anti sexualité en
faut au moins dont on parle et non parce
que je laisse à mon rapport décor et une
dimension
une dimension divine j'ai trop de
respect pour tout individu tout être
humain
à commencer par moi pour considérer que
le corps est un morceau de viande des
quelque chose qui se défait qui qui
pourrit et le rapport et la jouissance
le rapport d'essence et la jouissance
donne une idée plus précise de l'extase
que simplement un orgasme 1 coûte que
comme disait mon analyste qui laisse pas
grand chose
vous avez dit nous sommes autre chose
que de la matière oui croyons dieu le
terme croit revêtent un terme profane ça
a à voir avec la crédulité je ne crois
que ce que je vois
j'ai une sensation très exact de quelque
chose de deux magnifiques croyons l'âme
l'esprit oui quand vous dites on vit
seul et on meurt seul la solitude n'est
pas une erreur épouvantable c'est c'est
quelque chose d'exaltant parce que la
solitude ne veut pas dire être isolé ne
veut pas dire être séparés des autres
c'est être avec les autres et si je suis
conscient de ma solitude je peux encore
mieux comprendre celle des autres et la
souffrance de ceux qui ne la supporte
pas bien merci mademoiselle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous ont présenté double
jeu à la semaine prochaine
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu